[Música]
hablamos ahora de salud en directo
américa para ello ya está conmigo en el
estudio más romeros a la mar bienvenida
feliz lunes es también para ti un nuevo
estudio británico la clave sobre la
inmunidad contra el cubit 19 que a la
larga podría servir para así desarrollar
unas vacunas que sabemos sobre esto más
pues son noticias interesantes como
mínimo todavía no sabemos si
esperanzadora sobre este estudio que
sabemos lo que hace es detallar cómo
estas proteínas del cob y 19 del virus
del comil 19 como las reconocen las
células de que son unas de las
herramientas claves de la respuesta
inmune de las personas es un estudio con
trabajadores de la prim durante la
primera oleada de la pandemia que tenían
esta respuesta inmune las células t a
pesar de nunca haber sido contagiados
para detallar todo esto para saber más
sobre el estudio estamos con el doctor
carlos eduardo pérez como cada lunes
médico infectólogo de la universidad
nacional de colombia doctor muy buen
inicio de semana y empecemos por lo más
básico que son estas células t
recordemos marx que la respuesta
inmunológica tiene dos grandes grupos de
seis una que son las células de que
producen los anticuerpos que son los que
se dirigen en el caso del cohete a la
proteína de espiga y las células t que
se encargan ellas como serías de
neutralizar el virus ya no usan un
intermediario sino estas células que
directamente afectan a las células
infectadas las células que son
fundamentales en la respuesta
inmunológica y se usan en diversas áreas
digamos control de infecciones control
de tumores y muchas cosas más ahora el
torre pregunto cómo responden estas
células t a las infecciones él comunicó
raúl las células t lo que producen
inmunidad celular y es lo que nos va a
dar la prolongación de la respuesta
inmunológica y además de eso algunas de
estas células van a ser capaces de
neutralizar el virus activamente incluso
si kalle la presencia él tiene un tiempo
después activadas por unas células de
memoria estas células que son muy
importantes para poder prolongar la
respuesta inmunológica y es lo que se
está explicando paulmann
doctor estos trabajadores lo decíamos al
inicio de la crónica no dieron respuesta
a positivo por esta respuesta inmune de
las células t sin haber conocido sin
haber estado en contacto con el virus
directamente del coi 19 nunca dieron
positivo en un pc eres por ejemplo cómo
se explica esto
lo que sucede en el estudio es que
fueron trabajadoras de la salud
expuestos al vix y algunos desarrollaron
enfermedad pero una porcentaje que no
desarrolló la enfermedad el estudio se
centró en esas personas que no habían
desarrollado la enfermedad a pesar de la
exposición que han tenido con sus
compañeros y lo que encontraron es que
no eran la respuesta esta vez sino la
respuesta de células en las que impedían
la replicación viral es decir ya no la
neutralización de grant la entrada del
virus al epitelio respiratorio sino la
multiplicación del virus y si estas
células que actúan en estas personas son
un punto importante para entender la
respuesta inmune y diseñar las nuevas
vacunas doctor entonces le pregunto qué
implicaciones tiene este descubrimiento
para una futuras vacunas
claro al encontrar que las células no
solamente son capaz de neutralizar la
entrada del virus sino que algunas
células impiden la replicación del virus
si se puede neutralizar esa replicación
viral muy probablemente sea cortar la
cadena de transmisión recordemos que
nuestras vacunas son muy buenas pero no
perfectas porque evitan la enfermedad
pero no evitan la transmisión un tipo de
vacunas de estas terminaría con la
replicación viral y por ende sería como
una estocada final al afán del doctor en
ese mismo sentido hay vacunas que ya
estén funcionando a través de estas
células y reforzando su acción es decir
sabemos si verdaderamente podría
funcionar
si hay muchas vacunas que activan las
células y que hacen que por ejemplo la
vacuna sea una sola vez en la vida
vacunas por ejemplo para el neumococo
conjugada se activan las células y
prolongan y es una sola aplicación para
toda la vida estas este tipo de
inmunidad se conoce muchas de las
vacunas también lo producen aquí lo
interesante es que este es un nuevo
target un nuevo objetivo para impedir la
replicación y que sería un nuevo inicio
para otro tipo de
reformulación de las vacunas a las que
tenemos actualmente pues el doctor como
siempre entonces estaremos muy atentos a
cómo avanza la ciencia como que más
cosas sabemos y cómo pueden afectar
también en la lucha contra la pandemia
de kobe 10 y más así es el doctor y marc
muchísimas gracias ahora yo los despido
para ir con nuestro segundo invitado del
día